news of the takeover announced on
military on television
this video one of the few to capture the
moment a member of parliament was
whisked away in a pre-dawn raid
where too is anyone's guess
[Music]
among the many arrested civilian leader
aung san tsu
chi and other high-ranking members of a
ruling party
national league for democracy in a
statement she denounced a coup as an
attempt to put the country back under a
dictatorship
adding i urge people not to accept this
to respond
and wholeheartedly to protest against a
coup by the military
the dramatic escalation marks a
culmination of a bitter dispute over
november's general election
an election which saw suchi's party
coast to victory in a landslide
but which the military insists was
fraught with irregularities
claims that the country's election
commission has dismissed his baseless
news of the coup has drawn strong
international condemnations
it's nothing short of outrageous
deeply disturbing this is unacceptable
the international community rejects what
has happened
that leaders of the world are united
uh in their revulsion of this of this
this illegal act on the streets of
myanmar
the coup is seen as a sad setback for
many
little more than a decade after it
celebrated its transition to democracy
i feel the army assaulted the people
when it staged this cue on the civilian
government
a government elected by our people
our country's just a bird learning to
fly
now the army broke her wings
as myanmar's catapulted towards an
uncertain future
many are rushing to stock up on
essentials bracing for an end to
democracy
as they know it and let's get more now
we are joined
by dave grunibaum who is a journalist
who spent many years reporting from
myanmar he joins us now
from malaysia uh dave what else can you
tell us about this coup
how it has been organized and how it's
unfolding
yeah well you've really got to just
begin by pointing to the
commander-in-chief of the military
senior general
min long uh he hits the mandatory
retirement age of 65
later this year and it's no secret that
he had his eyes
on the presidency but given the results
of the november elections where the
national league for democracy won more
than 80
percent of the available seats and won
by a landslide there really seemed to be
no way he could get there legitimately
anytime soon now as you said a minute
ago
uh the military was making strong
accusations a week ago
um saying that there was election fraud
uh but the elections commission
rejected when i say strong they were
being strong about what they're alleging
they didn't show any
proof though of this so the election
commission rejected saying there was no
widespread voter fraud
and then there were real concerns since
last week that we could have a coup
uh those concerns seem to tamp down over
the weekend with statements that came
out of the military
but then we saw what happened uh early
this morning with political leaders
being detained put under guard some
political activists detained as well
and how about the people of myanmar how
is this likely to impact them
well a huge blow to these people while
the military does have
uh some supporters in this the
overwhelming majority of this population
clearly supports aung shu aung su chi in
the national league for democracy
clearly against this coup now aung
sangsuchi there was a statement
released today by the nld in her name uh
where she calls the actions
uh to the country called putting this
and puts it back under dictatorship
uh in aung san sushi urging people not
to accept this
um the question is are we going to see
at some point
some some real protest public protests
and demonstrations
by the people that would be quite a move
to make because this is a country keep
in mind it's spent
uh close to 50 years under a
a repressive military dictatorship that
in some cases not only put down public
demonstrations
not only violently but in some cases
using deadly force
given all of that even all of that
background and context i mean the
military
says that they will be taking control
for at least a year
um do we have any indications of what
they
are planning
so i mean this they have things are very
opaque in myanmar uh
in the military and it's always been
that way but
the military has got to try attempt to
somehow try to bring some legitimacy to
what they're doing
they're talking about what they claim
was widespread um
elections fraud they're going to have to
try to keep bringing that bringing that
up but
the simple fact is this is that the
people there's there's going to be very
little changing of minds over this
the people who are with aung suchi
believe that the nld won that election
uh legitimately they're going to dig in
deeper and the people who support the
military
they're going to dig in deeper so now
the military is going to be
left as an unpopular leading leaders in
this country
how are they going to manage that how
are they going to manage the economy
which they completely mismanaged during
50 years of june to rule
and how they going to manage the health
prices going on with a pandemic as well
all questions really up in the air right
now so many open questions dave
grunerbaum uh
putting it into all context for us so we
really appreciate that
and let's get more now we are joined by
kaylee long she joins us from london
from the human rights group amnesty
international she's a researcher on
myanmar welcome to the program and thank
you so much for joining us
we understand that amnesty says this is
an ominous moment for myanmar
what are your fears for the people there
people on the ground obviously
communications have been patchy but
people are really worried this myanmar
has such a history of uh
brutal military dictatorships and so for
a lot of people there this uh
rings some serious alarm bells and you
can see that in the response from the
international community
um it's the situation as always is is
fluid and
kind of unclear at the moment but this
uh is definitely cause for concern for a
military that has such a bad track
record with human rights
impunity indeed you've mentioned the
reaction uh world leaders have of course
condemned to the military's actions
but what can the international community
really do
this is really going to be a critical
moment and a big test for the
international community
and we've seen in
international accountability for
atrocities by the military
against the rohingya and rakhine state
but at this stage uh
i think everyone will be watching it
very closely and hopefully uh
speaking up on any human rights abuses
and violations of international law
uh we know that aung sang has allegedly
presided over human rights abuses in in
myanmar
amnesty international is calling for her
release just give us the background
there
yes for many years aung san tsuchi had
been a political prisoner herself and
then
we've been very critical of her during
her time in government and the
human rights violations her government
has overseen so we actually uh
rescinded the award that she was given
for being a human rights icon
and so now these detentions
of the government of senior figures do
appear to be illegal
and so we're calling for their release
unconditionally
kaylie long from the human rights group
amnesty international joining us from
london
thank you so much for sharing that
perspective
and mount zarni is a burmese academic
and human rights activist based in
london
joining us now on the program dr zarni
thank you so much for your time
um i understand that you have said that
the coup exposed the big lie of fragile
democracy in myanmar
what did you mean by that
well the big lie that uh you know we
have been
fed up by the burmese uh military
and in fact as with the help of san
tsuji
is that burma is democratizing uh
you know under the um leadership of our
son tsuji
but we you know some of us who have
studied this uh you know our own country
for the last 30 years
professionally and also been involved in
politics no this is not completely
untrue
if you look at the constitution of um
you know 2008 which was drawn up
and adopted by the military itself
this coup has been preemptively
made legal and constitutional there are
nine pages in this constitution
that preemptively legalizes
any coup that is deemed necessary
by the commander-in-chief on grounds of
national security if you read the
burmese language statements coming out
of the office of the commander-in-chief
the chief coup maker you will know
that the military is using the language
of national security
not simply you know widespread
voter frauds and also i think
this is also a very very orwellian coup
in that the coup
makers call on san tsuji and mp
elects selfish ambitious
anti-democrats that are jeopardizing
the the democratic system therefore the
coup
is presented as a move in the
right direction so where is the hope
then given all of that for myanmar right
now i mean do you do you have much faith
for example in the international
community's
response and the ability to exert
pressure on the country
uh i am afraid not much uh
hope i am not seeing the
light at the end of the tunnel 10 years
and uh you know three years sorry um
two election cycle of the or yes two
election cycles since 2010
and the international community
so-called you know un
uh um member states for investors
and whatnot they have failed to
end even uh you know what is the
textbook example of a full-fledged
genocide against that you know one
national minority
and then they cannot be expected beyond
you know empty condemnations uh to do
anything to reverse this anti-democratic
trend
but but like i said you know that one
big casualty uh in a way a good one
is that the big lie that we
as a country are moving towards
democracy
that has been proven completely untrue
by the very military itself and so that
is something
that i welcome although coup is you know
something that no democrat would welcome
a very sobering assessment of what is
happening right now in myanmar we thank
you so much for joining us
burmese academic maung zarni we
appreciate it
thank you
and we are joined now by young hee lee
former un special rapper tour on myanmar
she is joining us from seoul south korea
thank you so much for your time this
afternoon
what is your reaction to what is
happening right now in myanmar
this is really an outrageous situation
and it's a
direct assault to democracy and the
myanmar's
people's will when they elected
nld as their second democratic
government
what do you think that this means right
now for me the country's
experiment with democracy um is there
any hope left
that we might see some progress on that
front
it's going to put back myanmar and its
strive for democracy for many decades
now i think
and it's really too early to see how
situations will unfold in myanmar but i
i really think that the people's efforts
to achieve democracy will be set back
quite a while we've seen international
condemnations coming forward from from
from rights groups from
from leaders around the world what do
you make of the internationals community
community's ability right now to put
pressure on the country
amid this coup
well i think first of all the security
council needs to
convene and it would be necessary for
them to send a delegation
into myanmar to see to monitor what is
really
happening and try to try to engage in
some
talks with both sides
you're very familiar with the military
you're also very familiar um
with the united nations and its inner
workings
you know that that what you've just
mentioned there
how do you see you know the realistic
prospects
of the military allowing that into the
country
it will not but i think uh well
especially
with this military coup there are
definite
indications that the men alike that the
chief commander
has been endorsed uh had his blessings
from
china and from russia and so the two
permanent members of the security
council wouldn't will not
adhere to any request to send a
delegation and i think this is where the
international community should really
pressure
apply more pressure on these two states
how how could they possibly do that i
mean because as you've mentioned myanmar
the military has these two very powerful
back backers
china and russia um and
do they have any interest in in a more
democratic myanmar
i am afraid that's where the problem
lies they really do not have any more
interest in a democratic
myanmar and i think this is where they
the u.n israel is up to another test
and and help see how the secretary
general navigates
his power or his negotiating
negotiating skills into seeing that
for now once and for all we will
have uh myanmar not to go down this
dark lane and this is where the
international community
failed me among its people and the u.n
has ultimately failed myanma and its
people
um there there might be talks at this
hour of of of
of sanctions similar to the ones that we
we saw previously
um on myanmar you know uh arms embargo
we've also seen in the past
just walk us through those measures and
the impacts that that
they have had in the past and what
lessons have potentially been
been learned um for what measures might
be considered now going forward
the targeted sanctions against this
corporations uh
economic uh enterprises held by the
military its cronies and its associates
these will work and and we have seen
that they
have started to work and i think this is
what scares
me online is that once he loses
power his assets his fortunes will
disappear or he will not have access to
his fortunes
and this is what prompted i mean online
for this
uh to stage this coup of course the
people of myanmar are a huge concern at
this hour can can you just walk us
through the impact that
all of this is likely to have on them
well you know this is amid the
chronovirus pandemic
people have suffered a lot and for years
they still
they suffered crimes against humanity
war crimes and there was a genocide in
rakhine
and in ethnic states there there still
is
vibrant war and clashes and and people
have already suffered from
lack of access to basic
fundamental human rights and now with
this coup
uh banks are closed media uh
news outlets uh well aside from
government news
internet and there will be another
curfew
and so the lives of the people is going
to be
um people are going to be in a more dire
situation
and now having said this treatment
or testing for coronavirus i really
worry
if people will be tested or if people
will receive
treatment if they're tested positive
with coronavirus well we thank you so
much for joining us
with that sobering assessment of what is
happening right now yanghili
former un special rapper tour on myanmar
we really appreciate it
thank you so what action can the world
expect from germany
well jurgen heart chairs the german
parliament's foreign affairs working
group
he joins us from his constituency in the
country's west
welcome to dw sir beyond condemning what
is happening
in myanmar what action is berlin
proposing
first i'm very much disappointed about
the situation now in myanmar
we saw a clear democratic election in
november
we have no question marks behind the
result of that election
and therefore we see that the civil
powers in that country the so to say
also pro western powers
are won the election and have the right
to build a government
and what we see today let's it gives a
lot of question marks
i don't know what other powers might be
behind that
in january there was a visit of the de
facto foreign minister of china
to the militaries to the generals in
myanmar
and maybe he has encouraged them to to
take over power in that country and i
ask the european union to go
into detail and behind that what we saw
there
okay what should germany do now
i think in europe on the european level
as the european union we should think
about
personal sanctions against those who are
responsible for this
situation we also have to think about
our
civil economic aid program we started
with the
democratic majority and democratic
government in
myanmar this program
maybe needs to be postponed or
interrupted until
a point where we can say we have a new
and better situation in the country
but i think it's too early to judge on
that
at the moment but these are the
questions we have on the table
what sort of sanctions and against whom
a normal and effective instrument is to
sanction those people who are
responsible for this military
coup because they normally in those
countries are also traveling around the
world they
using their credit cards and other
things and therefore we have to
to be aware that potentially we can
sanction them
and the second is that we have a program
of economic aid
to that country started with the german
ghee i said
and other organizations and i'm i'm not
in the position
now today to say we have to skip that
but we have to go
into the details and go behind that does
it make sense to continue or should we
interrupt it
until the military step down and give
power back to the people
we heard from a former u.n rapporteur on
myanmar a little just before you you
came on
and we heard from from her that its
allies china and russia have not played
a constructive role in promoting
democracy
in myanmar can berlin or should the
brussels pressure put pressure
on the country's military backers
this is what i'm also afraid of that
the generals were stimulated by
probably the wizard of the chinese head
of the communistic foreign department
uh that they are encouraged to do that
also due to the situation with corona
where
things are not so clear in the region
and if if we have a proof for that
that china or maybe another foreign
power is behind that good
eta this might be on the table of the
united nations security council and
also of the european union but at the
moment i think we have not
no proof for that but we have a lot of
question marks
okay so lots of questions this only
happened today i i i'd be
interested to know how quickly you want
people to act
when should that we when should
sanctions be imposed
uh when should uh germany be uh
re-evaluating its economic assistance to
myanmar
we will have the topic of situation in
myanmar on the foreign affairs committee
in germany
next wednesday if i put that on the
agenda i think also
all the other parties will agree on that
and we have will have a debate on what
we have to do and i also expect a
a message from the european union from
the
high representative um borrel and the
foreign ministers of the european
union because i think it's very
necessary that we act
uh um together and not uh as a single
action only from germany
but i think we should use the next 24
hours to
uh to develop a common position
thank you so much for joining us that's
very clear uh jurgen hart a member of
the german parliament thank you
goodbye
you